direction mon à présent à la découverte
d'un atelier de reconstruction pour les
femmes victimes de violences physiques
ou psychologiques
et si les scream pouvait les remettre
sur pied et leur permettre de retrouver
la confiance qui leur manque c'est en
tout cas le pari relevé chaque mois par
les encadrants de ce projet
thérapeutique unique en région centre
plus d'explications dans ce reportage
d'audrey champigny depuis un an chaque
mois
dominique participe à une séance des
scream thérapeutique harcelé
psychologiquement et agressé
sexuellement par son conjoint
cette mère de famille tente de se
reconstruire retrouver des valeurs une
estime de soi et sortir plus forte mais
on va qu'on peut faire permettre de
sortir la colère qu'on a en france
ça permet de reprendre confiance en soi
de d'essayer de déculpabiliser par
rapport à ce qu'on a vécu on ressort
avec plus de sérénité mais c'est encore
beaucoup de chemins partout on pense
d'abord à soi effectivement parce que
c'est vraiment l'essentiel c'est la
priorité c'est d'être bien parce que si
on n'est pas bien on ne peut pas être
bien pour ses enfants
j'ai vraiment mois de plus pour moi
d'ailleurs personne ne savait que je
faisais ces ateliers des screen c'était
vraiment quelque chose mon jardin secret
pour ces femmes les scream est une sorte
de catalyseur
chaque séance est relié à un thème
apprendre à se défendre attaquer se
faire respecter ou encore savoir poser
des limites
l'objectif est aussi de faire ressortir
ces énergies négatives et parfois
meurtrières comme la plupart des
patients que l'on a sont entre
guillemets dissocier le but du jeu c'est
devrait associer la tête et le corps en
utilisant le saint roch un amour plus
rapide
on a une utilisation
du corps c'est à dire qu'on va chanter
le cerveau en utilisant leurs réflexes
ça va très vite le sabre on n'a pas le
temps de réfléchir et donc c'est le
corps qui trouve les solutions et qui
général on trouve des bonnes solutions
c'est-à-dire qu'on corps est capable de
se défendre à chaque session les femmes
sont épaulés par des professionnels de
santé médecins kinés et psychologues
moi je suis là pour accompagner les
femmes qui pendant l'atelier vivrait une
émotion qui les déborderait ou de la
colère qui sont pas bien voilà moi je
suis là pour vraiment accompagner et
cadres et si il ya un souci quelconque
en cinq ans et ateliers mis en place par
l'association stop aux violences
sexuelles
en partenariat avec l'association dirait
guérir et le club des scream 2 m'ont
accueilli près de 70 femmes